الينا من جنيف العقيده لكزندر بوتر فاير
رئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه السويسريه
عقيده الكسندر مع غموض وضع مدينه باقمت
الاستراتيجيه ما هو برايك السيناريو
الميداني
الذي يبدو مرجحا وقوعه
بالمخاطره والمواجهزه ما يمكن ان نقوله في
هذا الخصوص
الروس ضعفوا من عدد قواتهم في بحموت وحول
منطقه الشيء الثاني
روسيا لا تريد الان ان تسيطر على المدينه
هي قامت فقط
باحكام التوقع ومحاصره المدينه الشيء
الثالث
روسيا
بصدد احراز اختراقات وتقدم في الشمال من
اجل الدخول والتسلل خلف الخطوط الاوكرانيه
اذا تقول يعني سوريا ليست بصدد اتجاه
الحسم بل محاصره
محاصره ربما محاصره ماريوبل ولكن الى متى
ماذا تستفيد من ذلك
الاستفاده من قبل الروس هي انهم يسيطرون
على الارض شيئا فشيئا وهم يلحقون خسائر
كبيره
بالاوكرانيين وهم يسيطرون على خطوط
الامداد وهم يقومون
تحيد مجموعه من القوات قوات النخبه
الاوكرانيه الى ان هذا هذه استراتيجيه
روسيا في المرحاضرين طبعا روسيا ايضا
تتكبد خسائر كبيره في هذه العمليه شكرا لك
العقيده الكسندر
فوتساب فايل الرئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه
السويسريه المتحدث شكرا لك